a lot of times men will meet what they
think is a good woman and I've covered
the story of Tyrese Gibson getting
divorced and he has spoken about how he
met his ex-wife in a $15 sundress she
signed the prenup she was okay with
everything and now she is taking him to
the cleaners in divorce court and for
months I've seen Tyrese really asking on
different shows where he went wrong he
wasn't Unfaithful he loved his wife he
really has no idea why the marriage
dissolved and this is how a lot of men
in their 40s and 50s hit the red pill
they they really think that they have
their life figured out they have the
woman that they love they're good with
it for the rest of their life and then
one day their woman comes home and wants
a divorce and they don't know why